I am making friends with the mooch in
case Trump tries to send me to Gitmo
that's what I want to know I gotta get
moe no let me tell you right surprise
okay and to me if you could redo one
thing while you were at the right house
what would it be
that's a good question probably the Ryan
Lizza call I probably wouldn't had that
one right but you are in ten days you
actually it's how much you accomplished
you know you can't did we knock out a
lot of the leakers and a lot of the
unnecessary internecine warfare we
definitely did that
and the America two biggest leaker has
gotten knocked out with me in the
American Revolution George Washington
only fought nine battles the only one
three of them deal with Amen Richard
Haass what will u.s. global leadership
look like post Trump know if there is
ever such a thing that's a good question
the issue of whether Trump's an
aberration or whether he's a trend and
to what extent trumpism is there and I
actually I worry about that a little bit
he's a feature or a glitch except right
and what comes next and yeah I also
whoever comes next they're not going to
inherit the world that he inherited it's
gonna be a world that's been degraded
it's gonna be a tough job when you come
after him in the country it's not clear
to me is ready to play the sort of role
that we historically have okay
yes of course true but again I see it
differently I think that the the world
the economic engine of the United States
I mean we have a real shot now to double
the economy in 18 years we can clip away
at 3% growth it'll eliminate a lot of
the entitlement issues that we have I
think we're gonna bolster eliminate
entitlement issues meaning yeah well you
have a 17 trillion dollar economy now
yeah when you get it to 34 trillion
it'll it'll take war yeah you'll double
our in 18 years if you grow 3% I think
it's a matter
well no I mean you're gonna do it to
Cornell you know that's called be
stronger and you can have a lot more
beachfront property on that hairline
well we're gonna see what we're going to
see the visual and property in Nebraska
[Applause]
okay its interest rates are going up in
part because the tax cut was deeper than
it needed to be in part because the
economy was already growing okay the
dead is going to skyrocket which is
going to force rates up we're already
seeing wage wages going up causing again
the Fed to raise rates what this is
going to do is slow the economy and what
this is going to do I think is
ultimately create a crisis you know
we're out climate change the other big
crisis our debt we're gonna have to
raise the rates significantly to fund
our debt there's no way we are gonna
grow out of the 13 trillion dollars of
it no yeah but that was a big difference
you did to unnecessary big difference
when you're coming out of a crisis like
2007/8 right now we're creating the
crisis it is amazing when we're you guys
are not acknowledging the fact
not acknowledging this is a bipartisan
indictment on the table there's a
thirteen trillion dollars of debt was
added over the last nine years I know
you just I mean when you guys are out of
power we cannot spend a nickel as soon
as you get into power it's like just
write the check
Richard knows that the pay-as-you-go
legislation that he put in place in the
George Bush one administration okay well
I came up with the pay-as-you-go
legislation this is a house started to
reline start at the right side the
budget we shouldn't be talking about
this as if there's you guys as if
there's two parties here the Republican
Party is a broken party and there are
people who have served the Republican
Party that was and there are people who
are volunteering to serve the Republican
Party that will be but it is not is not
it is not just it is not to say that we
as Anthony said when he denigrated the
past Republican presidents is important
to understand that something new is
taking the place of the Republican Party
that shouldn't you and I all right there
are there are definitely changing both
sides I'm not denigrating the past were
both young presidents you you've racked
up twenty trillion dollars of debt on
the American people you think the swamp
is a really good business model for the
American people I think 17 years of war
is that fifteen thousand calorie house
that's one I don't think it's trainable
you know I think it's a gold-plated hot
tub but when Trump no no I don't think
it was a lie I think it was an ambition
as down he's a liar you kept their great
raise your raise your hand in the room
but like raise your hand in the
raise your hand but like never told but
that's not come on that's not enough you
know it's no easy sales guys but again
it does not new you don't like the fact
that he's not not presidential president
normal like as soon as the State of the
Union is over it's the greatest
residents didn't why not like that not
like that what what you were living in a
normative world what you are it's what
you accept who you are and and it's like
and I think one of the one of the
peculiar unexpected gifts of Donald
Trump is that he has caught a lot of
people to understand both the
preciousness of truth and also the need
to defend institutions like the FBI and
the CIA maybe they wouldn't have gotten
the big applause they got tonight in
this room I think probably three years
ago or four years ago if you told the
people in this room that Edward Snowden
and Julian Assange were not heroes they
might think differently I think now we
all understand better we understand they
were working for what they were working
to accomplish well and we see it in
front of us now I love them together
quite that way Julian Assange is a
little different and the other guy and
Julian Assange somehow did get a little
too in with Russia and very close to the
Trump campaign I'm not sure that your
anger towards the Trump is clouding your
judgment but good anger massive class
would help you think a little bit that
is such a Michael Corleone line
it's bad father curry your anger is
don't let your anger cloud your judgment
no Haley don't let your anger cloud your
judgment but don't let your ambitions
also cloud your judgment what does that
even mean you're talking about my
ambition we're talking about it already
you know I lived a great life for you
and time' i wouldn't let her try to
serve the country and help the middle
and lower middle class people that are
struggling in this country it was got a
wake up brother it was Donald you're up
you're living in like an ivory tower you
gotta start with Trump a New York Post
should get some of the Mexico and thing
as a suppository Ameen good okay I'm not
a weak guy but you mean and you're angry
so Canadian to be that way donna Brazile
aside from we're not Trump the Democrats
have big ability unable to craft a
simple clear appealing message of voters
what is it going to take for Democrats
to wake up to this we want an economy
that works for everyone
period American especially those
Americans who are still struggling and
by the way is Black History Month you're
like unemployment went up a little bit I
want to just say two something to the
president if you get get him on the
phone tomorrow stop leave us alone
[Applause]
started going down and kept going down
and kept going down it took back up so
just leave us alone in my show last week
was all about how he picks fights with
black people yeah leave us alone I think
he picks for black people and then on
cue we did it with jay-z
well I had a list this long from Colin
Kaepernick and Obama tendu he does seem
to the war Widow he'd see me purposely
get any credit display my sitting with
the rainbow coalition 25 years ago and
getting the well he doesn't know I don't
know you have to refresh my memory what
the 25 years ago what
he was part of Jesse Jackson's rainbow
[Applause]
the Central Park five when he went after
them even after they were innocent
strikes as they seem they asked me to
question I want to know what your honor
cuz you you are you are I'm on the
Michael Corleone like he is very Michael
Corleone he doesn't raise his voice he's
a quiet killer yeah a little bit too
honest though I'm not like the typical
backstabbing Washingtonians well I'm I
Tina Turner I'm a private dancer baby
but I don't dance for that kind of money
there's an after-party done I'm gonna
try the way time for me to suck my own
[ __ ]
you